welcome back to overtime it was a crazy
day on the field and an even crazier one
off of it here to address the crisis on
his home he's coach Patrick hey guys
thank you any questions social media
chatter about you and your girlfriend
can you address that
it's tough we get along well we love
each other it's fine
still some miscommunication you know the
other night she called while I was
watching a John Madden documentary and
that can't happen you know we're far
enough them to the relationship business
you should know better I ended up
apologizing somehow anyway but do you
can give us a little backstory into your
storybook romance yeah my girlfriend
I've been seeing each other a long time
and fall was always tough you know she
says that she loses me from September to
early February and then she only gets me
for six months because of football
season and I look at it as the glass
being half full she sees it as
half-empty I'm like hey will you get me
from February you know to September it
should be thankful so focus on the
positive you always got to do that in
relationship no comment
[Music]